[Musique]
le duel tant attendu a donc eu lieu hier
soir 2h30 d'échange où aucun des deux
candidats n'a cédé au reculer une
ségolade royale qui s'est révélée pugnas
un Nicolas Sarkozi qui est resté
imperturbable récite cette soirée où la
forme et ce qu'elle pouvait révéler des
personnalités de chacun était aussi
important que les arguments échangés
Arnaud bouté et Chloé le comte souriante
volontairement décontractée elle arrive
la première vêtue d'un tailleur sombre
et d'un chemisier blanc quelques
secondes plus tard à 20h50 précisément
Nicolas Sarkozi entre sur le plateau les
deux candidats se croisent pour la
première fois une poignée de main rapide
puis elle à gauche lui à droite le débat
peut commencer très rapidement il tourne
à l'affrontement sécurité délinquence et
bien sûr les 35 he ou nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde on ne fait ça il
y a pas un pays pas un seul madame
socialiste ou pas qui a retenu la
logique du partage du temps de travail
qui est une erreur monumentale les 35
heur n'ont pas créé d'emploi et les 35
heur ont été responsables d'autre chose
de plus grave encore c'est la rigueur
salariale qui fait que nos salaires sont
trop bas d'abord si vous pensez que les
35 heur ont créé autant de dégâts
pourquoi ne les avez-vous pas supprimé
de loi tente de garder son calme elle
opte pour l'offensive et l'accuse
violemment d'avoir supprimé un
dispositif qui facilitait l'accès à
l'école des enfants handicapés où avec
moi tous les enfants handicapés mentaux
étaient accueillis à l'école maternelle
dès lors que les parents le demandaient
alors laissez de côté vos tribunaux les
démarches des parents qui en ont assez
déjà de leur souffrance et d'avoir vu
leurs enfants ne pas pouvoir être
inscrits lors des rentrées scolaires
pendant lesquelles vous étiez au
gouvernement laissez cela de côté parce
que la façon là dont vous venez faire de
l'immoralité politique par rapport à une
politique qui a été détruite et à
laquelle je tenais particulièrement
parce que je sais à quel point cela
soulageé les parents devant leurs
enfants accueillis à l'école et c'est
vous qui avveit cassé cette politique là
cet écart entre le discours et des et
les actes surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfants handicapés n'est pas
acceptable et je suis très en colère et
les parents et les familles qui vous et
les parents non je me cal monz pas du
doigt avec cet index Poé parce que
franchement non je me calmer pas non je
ne me calmerai pas je ne me calmer pas
utal président de la ré 2h40 de face à
faceace d'opposition sur la croissance
sur la dette et pour conclure Segolen
Royal a tenu à s'adresser aux Français
face caméra sur le fond sur la forme
chaque détail avait hier soir son
importance qui me soutiennent et avec
nous sur ce plateau